mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
maler und malerinnen male
musiker und musikerinnen machen musik
sind kreativ doch warum
was treibt sie an warum ich kreativ bin
das bewahrt mich davor verrückt zu
werden wir fragen heute welches
geheimnis steckt hinter kreativen
schaffen beschreibt heidi happy zb ihre
betörende songs ein kulturplatz aus dem
reich der kreativität
[Musik]
dapd
er ist
[Musik]
ja was wäre das leben ohne musik ohne
jene menschen die sie komponieren und
spielen
herzlich willkommen bei kulturplatz wir
fragen heute danach wo die kunst egal
welcher sparte überhaupt herkommt wo
herziehen kreative ihre urkraft wann
werden sie von der muse geküsst und
warum überhaupt sind menschen kreativ
beispielsweise die luzerner musikerin
heidi happy sie gehört zu den
eigenwilligsten musikerinnen der
schweizer szene seit mehr als zehn
jahren schon existiert die kunstfigur
heidi happy hinter der sich die
luzernerin priska zemp verbirgt
die musik der multi instrumentalistin
ist über die jahre facettenreicher und
tiefgründiger geworden
[Musik]
die einflüsse ihrer musik reichen von
folk bis hin zu klassik
ihre musikalische begabung kommt nicht
von ungefähr
brisk us mutter eine sopranistin brachte
ihr bereits mit sechs jahren das
klavierspielen bei ihr debütalbum back
together zeichnete sie in der nähe von
amsterdam auf wo sie studierte auch in
den folgenden jahren zog es sie immer
wieder in die stadt mit den vielen
brachten
um der zunehmenden bekanntheit zu
entfliehen
[Musik]
das davis hier
sie arbeitete schon mit schweizer musik
größen wie jan o
diese heraus
mit stephan eicher mit dem sie das erste
mal im monat sind
die wsd hause sind
wer das ist
diese weise
[Musik]
wie viele instrumente sie spielt weiß
sie vielleicht selbst gar nicht klavier
cello gitarre vibraphon mandoline
melodica als multitalent komponiert sie
filmmusik und für ihr album hiding with
the wolves auch für ein ganzes orchester
und im moment entsteht ein neues album
[Musik]
es kratzt mit trotz die stadt für ihr
braucht geht es über die grundstücke
heidi happy was ein ticket für zwei
richtungen unterwegs reicht die hab ich
schaffte zum superstar so persönliche
text geschrieben dass ich mir alle
freiheiten als übertrieben hoffentlich
nicht genau stimmt und ich das ist
einfach teil die halbwegs ausblick trotz
ein praktisches problem kann idee lacht
sie und mittlerweile bin ich wenn ich
auf tour bin ich heidi und seiten wer
also unter stelle mich also vor und
priska wenig der heime nach hinten und
toni kurze ganz erfrischend neue
industrien zum beispiel warum bist du so
sehr geliebt sondern mich beschäftigt
und sich mini art aus verarbeitet das
muss irgendwie rossello
und ich hatte zwar schon alt und ich
habe überreden aber es ist für mich
wieder mal etwas anders wenn ich was
mache ich dafür bessern wir in ironische
note trainierten wir packen das ist
nicht so tragisch nehmen grafisch und
banken sehen und die melodie ist egal
was passiert wenn die mikrofone
was macht ja genau also am see wie die
das machen
oder reden nicht viel verschlafen aber
sofort bis 10 und die kasse zwar nicht
geschlafen und man weiß ich wie dem
jugendgericht zurück
oder wenn ich zunehme ist die heimat
kommt die mache ich gerade jetzt
versorgen und sitzen auf einmal zeigen
was machen wir hier
keine einfache frage warum bist du
kreativ der filmemacher hermann vaske
hat sie weltweit prominenten
künstlerinnen und künstlern gestellt
entstanden ist ein projekt das tief nach
den motiven schrift
über 30 jahre lang war er unterwegs
hermann vaske regisseur und
forschungsreisender in sachen
kreativität immer auf der suche nach dem
heiligen gral des kreativen schaffens
nach der motivation der künstlerinnen
und künstler für ihre kreativen
expedition immer mit der einen frage
[Musik]
warum sind sie kreativ mal reden wurde
zu einer endlosen serie von flüchtigen
treffen und kurzen gespräch alles begann
in london in den 1980 er wo hermann
vaske studierte und bei der renommierten
werbeagentur saatchi & saatchi arbeitete
westdeutschen grauen nach kriegsszenario
herauskatapultiert und plötzlich hat man
gemerkt da kann man sachen in fragen die
man sich nicht traute zu fragen es hat
einen richtig raus gelüftet und dann kam
diese frage why you create und diese
frage hatte endlos und jedem und jeder
gestellt david lynch angelina jolie
christoph schlingensief zum stephen
hawkins marina abramovic den dalai lama
david bowie yoko ono und john
haben wir jemanden vergessen
ach ja jörg wiebking vivienne westwood
und nelson mandela und vielen vielen
vielen mehr
[Musik]
es ist ein tauchen ein quasi auf die
topographie des ozeans der kreativität
um immer neue sachen entdeckt in vazquez
film spielt zuallererst die familiäre
umgebung eine große rolle
der zauber der kindheit ich blieb im
gleichen metier wie meine eltern meine
mutter ingrid bergman war schauspielerin
mein vater roberto rossellini regisseur
am anfang sind wir alle kreativ bauen
sandburgen verkaufen limonade und dann
greifen die praktischen dinge des lebens
ein
und nicht jeder bleibt kreativ wie
picasso sagte jedes kind ist ein
künstler
das problem ist nur ein künstler zu
bleiben während man älter wird
hermann vaske legt verschiedene
motivation schickten frei und findet die
individuellen beweggründe für
kreativität auch in den blockaden in den
feinden der kreativität wird killer in
der angst
angst kann durchaus ein treiber seien ja
weil oft sind die faktoren die die die
kreativität bedrohen genau die diese
antreiben warum ich kreativ bewahrt mich
davor verrückt zu werden
[Musik]
unsere größte angst im leben ist die
angst vor dem tod
alle haben angst davor wir reden nicht
darüber oder versuchen sie sogar zu
verleugnen
ich bin kreativ weil ich sex liebe
sexualität die treibende kraft für ihre
kreativität
es ist ein werkzeug in jedem kreativen
bereich gibt es bestimmte vokabular mit
denen man arbeitet und sexualität ist
eines davon
eine kreative seite funktioniert extrem
gut und ist extrem reichhaltig und sie
ist nicht in einer balance mit dem rest
meines lebens ein anderes leben leidet
sehr unter meiner vielseitigen
kreativität freundschaften leiden
beziehungen leiden die beziehung zu
meiner familie leidet
auf seiner reise trifft hermann vaske
immer wieder auf künstlerinnen und
künstler für die kreativität wie ein
unentrinnbaren schicksal zu sein scheint
genauso wie was besucher nach ihren
motiven
[Musik]
das ganze abenteuer schien außer
kontrolle zu geraten aber ich konnte
nicht mehr aufhören
das ist einfach eine eine
ewige reise zu neuen zielen
wenn sie ein ziel haben wenn sie wenn
sie irgendwo hin wollen in der kreativen
arbeit dann ist das ein wahnsinniger
beschleuniger deshalb führte hermann
vaske nicht nur interviews er ließ die
menschen die er befragte auch etwas
zeichnen ein bild machen
eine skizze einen satz schreiben
[Musik]
daraus entstand 2018 ein buch und eine
ausstellung mit über 300 exponaten
visuelle antworten und kommentare auf
die frage ich habe mich geschnitten im
gesicht und dieses blut habe ich auf ein
blatt papier gestrichen
[Musik]
das liegt mir im blut ich wache auf und
werde von etwas angetrieben
und das bringt mich dazu kreativ zu sein
[Musik]
hermann vaske freise zeigt wie
verschieden die motive sind was sie
verbindet ist etwas metaphysisches eine
sehnsucht etwas tun zu müssen zu
verändern
rebellisch zu sein und kreativität als
etwas zu entdecken was man einfach
intuitiv lebt als lebensform übrigens
hermann vazquez neues projekt heißt
while you're not creative
[Musik]
die musik
das war quadratmeter jedoch keine zu
schaffen
meistens und der han isch halt alle
instrumente zur verfügung als für mich
ist dieses paradies will seinem ruhm ich
alles was ich brauche die verbrauchten
wir speziell die umgebung für die ich
grüße dich rashid wird die schöpferisch
schaffen oder ist das wurscht doch so
aber also das ist glücklos und jetzt
habe ich das ein rotes haar
obwohl sich gerade die familie aber ich
habe schon mal nicht zurückziehen ort
unterwegs waren entlang schaffen und das
ist schon nochmal besonders ist also da
kann ich schon einmal angesteckt auch
unter einer dicken kopf und schauen was
passiert ja also man eben wie eine idee
aufgelaufen hellen die ich als normaler
geführtes kreuzungen ist
ich bin ja nicht reden wie so passen
oder so sitzt cello bass und mach ich
was anderes das licht besser ist es los
lässt
das probieren
[Musik]
tragen sie schon bestehen
das ist sehr meditativ was macht also
wovon du verletzt
jetzt passiert etwas größeres wäre also
mir aber jetzt wenn ich die wahrheit ja
schon ziemlich abgebrochen gefunden
nicht ehrlich ja aber das gefühl die
sache für die ich am wichtigste wurde
sind muss ich wohl zu viel und sind
sachen die ich mir fest dass und trieben
die emotional und dann mich auf jeden
user also ich war sehr lang ist fast nur
drei songs geschrieben wir sehen wir die
die emotionen
sie sehen wird mehr reden wir so fest
wie viel kann ich muss dir los werden
vielmehr werden wir tanzen oder so
wahnsinnig viel inszeniert chronik wie
viel gibt da ist muster wiederholt mit
was du los also meistens vorne also
welches spiel
[Musik]
ja klar kreatives schaffen ist der motor
vieler veränderungen aber innovation und
fortschritt verdammten mir nicht nur
einsame genies sondern auch den dialog
dem prozesshaften dahinter und davon
erzählt stefan kleines neues buch wie
wir die welt verändern
albert einstein seine
relativitätstheorie ein geniestreich der
physik geschichte
marie curie entdeckerin der
radioaktivität pionierin der
röntgentechnik steve jobs erfinder des
smartphones touch statt tasten es geht
nicht mehr ohne
zündende ideen großer genies verändern
die welt
diese populäre these erklärt
wissenschaftsautor stefan klein in
seinem buch kurzerhand zum mythos weil
keines der menschen die wir so alchemie
slogan für sich alleine gedacht hat
natürlich gibt es menschen die mehr
einflussreiche beiträge zu unserer
kultur geleistet haben als andere aber
keiner wirklich keiner dieser menschen
hat für sich alleine gearbeitet die
waren alle eingebunden in eine
zusammenarbeit mit mitstreitern mit
menschen die mit ihnen gedacht haben und
über die wird nicht geredet
die forschung gibt klein recht einsteins
hirn wird nach dessen tod untersucht
es stellt sich als gewöhnlich heraus bis
heute schreibt klein fehle ein nachweis
dafür dass geniale ideen biologischen
ursprungs sind
der kult ist nicht nur falsch und
unrealistisch ich finde ihn auch
gefährlich er ist gefährlich deswegen
weil wir da glauben die kreativen
fähigkeiten seien etwas was einige
wenigen haben und alle anderen nicht
und diesen aberglauben hat die
neuropsychologie also die hirnforschung
in den letzten jahren
gründlich widerlegt belegt dagegen ist
menschliche kreativität entwickelt sich
exponentiell die gattung homo braucht
anfangs ihre zeit neues zu schöpfen vom
einseitig behauenen steinwerkzeug bis
zum viel effizienteren zweiseitigen
vergehen mehr als 1 million jahre ab dem
späten mittelalter zündet die menschheit
den kreativitäts turbo zwischen
gutenbergs buchdruck und dem ersten
smartphone liegen noch gut 550 jahre
heute arbeiten maschinen dank
künstlicher intelligenz schneller und
präziser als der mensch verdrängen
maschinen demnächst die menschliche
kreativität
das können maschinen nicht weil
maschinen keine eigenen ziele verfolgen
können das sind brave soldaten also die
tun das was man ihnen befohlen hat ich
glaube dass wir viele ideen künftig
zusammen mit maschinen entwickeln werden
aber sie können unsere intelligenz nicht
ersetzen
kreativität ist heute ein ökonomischer
treiber kreative cluster wie das
gewerbehaus nerd in zürich-oerlikon
werten städte neu auf kathrin huber hat
über die wertschöpfung der
kreativwirtschaft ihre doktorarbeit
verfasst
die länder billiger produzieren und
darum in der einige statt wirkliche
krise geraten kreativ wirtschaftlich wie
ein teil oder arbeitsplatz in der
schweiz arbeiten fast eine halbe million
menschen in kreativen berufen
viele von ihnen selbstständig häufig
projektbezogen grenzen zwischen arbeit
und freizeit zu fließen die neue schöne
kreativ welt wird neue risiken sicher
wir ein anderer ort wo prekarisierung
dass man das früh erkannt hat oder sind
manche so schlecht muss billiger hand
oder irgendwie schon vom acker chancen
kann wer sich eine schlacht der milieu
aufgewachsen sind sondern sie wählen
dass wir selber spaß macht mache ihnen
gefallen es hingeht und könnten die
risiken und anteil ist die schlechte
absichtlicher sehr schwanken die auftrag
und im kommen und finden tages belauscht
die menschheit verändert die welt weil
sie dazu fähig ist
und wenn sie sich damit wieder einmal in
eine krise manövriert ist schwan
kreativität mehr gefragt denn je dass
die menschheit fähig war innerhalb von
acht monaten einen impfstoff für eine
globale pandemie zu entwickeln ich finde
dass ich finde das fantastisch und ich
glaube dass es viele probleme gibt die
keinen aufschub dulden kommende probleme
und aufgaben league ein genie der welt
alleine lösen kann
[Musik]
zurück in heidi happy es kreativ labor
dem musikzimmer
[Musik]
was dann geschah wenn überhaupt also hab
dazu gehören natürlich wenn ein lied auf
mich zukommt und denen die sagen zeigen
die musikklassen zeigen gut da was
gedreht wurden wie krankheit und
tanzmusik kosten ständig märkte extrem
besser gott wenn sie schon die musik
lasse und das ist für mich das größte
wenn ich möchte dass eine direkte
weltkrieg auf größten person ich war
immer gleich wechseln wie viel mittel
politisch sie zum beispiel in der musik
hat sich verändert und so wie ich wenn
ich irgendwo bin ihm einiges und ich
finde seine das betrifft und recht also
wenn ich mich bedanken dass ich mir so
wichtig dass es jeden wie agno wird und
die fand ich so doof wenn ich das nicht
wird mütze dass ich das öffentlich sagen
wenn ich das gefühl hat die vielleicht
sogar ohne hilfe nur stadtrats danke
abstimmen also bin ich froh dass ich
dieses paar leckereien
[Musik]
sie ist bleibt ziehen
nicht das so
[Musik]
ciao
[Gelächter]
sie schrieben kreativer prozess stören
immer durch schwierig sie so aufgebaut
wird ist dass wir nichts kommt
eigentlich einfach genau jedenfalls eben
sage ich ein bisschen bleibe ich noch
ich habe noch ein bisschen zu
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]